et pour raconter la télé il ya 40 ans eh
bien on va regarder ce qui s'est passé
entre le lundi 19 janvier le dimanche 25
janvier 1976 cette semaine là on
construit un contre saint jean d'arvey
les engrais près d'orléans à tour des
vandales pulvérise un sex-shop et une
librairie érotique
enfin dans la région des distillateurs
fabrique de l'eau de vie avec leur
alambic
il en existe encore comme ici à nous y
en indre et loire
c'est pour ça qu'on est là d'ailleurs le
journal de la semaine ça commence
maintenant
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir voici le sommaire de notre
journal
ils sont passés aux actes de samedi soir
contre de sex-shop
on commence donc avec un double attentat
contre un sex shop et une librairie
érotique à tour deux établissements
entièrement détruit il s'en est fallu de
peu qu'il ne tourne au drame d'ailleurs
en effet les deux bouteilles enflammées
jeté à l'intérieur du magasin 20 rouler
sans éclater au pied des vendeuses la
moquette ayant amorti le choc
deux attentats à la bombe revendiqué à
l'époque par un mouvement d'extrême
droite le mouvement citadelle et qui
existe encore en 2014 il s'affichait sur
les réseaux sociaux des poutrelles de 13
mètres de long pesant chacune plus de 6
tonnes
un ouvrage financé par la ccit du loiret
et qui va offrir de nombreux avantages
la suite c'est le journaliste qui
raconte
il apportera en effet une meilleure
desserte routière de la zone
industrielle saint jean de la ruelle
ingré il permettra aussi de relier
directement cette zone au péage de
l'autoroute a10 paris tours ainsi qu'à
la voie de raccordement de la
tangentielle ouest
autre actualité cette semaine là les
bouilleurs de cru qu'ils font chauffer
leurs alambic dans la région objectif à
l'époque produire une eau de vie maison
renvoyer sa balade en vélo c'est un
métier très dur j'ai à celle raison
credis pareil en supplément on a un
contrôle qui est vraiment très serré à
l'oeuf audace ans bonjour j'ai qui je
reviens jacky rochereau comment dit on
vous êtes distille atteint au bouilleur
de cru
non je dis si l'acteur bruyant ambulant
c'est quoi la différence
ça va moins je suis le bouilleur
ambulant schéma de progression et le
client c'est une bonne heure de crue
vous distillez quoi wajd disent ils des
prunes des pommes des poires des cerises
des du vin le marc de raisin de la pomme
ce que les gras porte qu'il récolte et
s'équivaut clients à tous les
particuliers tous les gens qui possèdent
des fruits comme non vous êtes et cd
taxés à 50% tous les gens qui sont
récoltant et vous fabriquer de l'eau de
vie à combien donner bon à 50 ont enfin
faut pas la faire trop forte pour avoir
les meilleurs parfums alors
expliquez-moi jusqu'en 1960
c'est un privilège que de pouvoir
fabriquer sur notre vie un produit un
privilège pendant que l'on pouvait
transmettre à ses héritiers jusqu'en
depuis c'est terminé tous les gens qui
l'ont ils peuvent le conserver mais deux
mais après quand les gens 17 c'est
terminé il n'y a plus brillé mais il ya
là des tags qui vont vous expliquer tout
à l'heure et vous c'est paru un
privilège c'est votre professeur moi
c'est ma profession je suis inscrit à la
chambre de métiers champ du commerce
les autorisations de par la douane et la
préfecture moi demain je prends ma
retraite je peux avoir un remplaçant et
pas de problème il ya notre hôte est
encore artisanal comme quand tu as bien
sportif que l'on viendra bien sûr faire
l'autre bis et c'est un peu de patience
et c'est pour moi c'est plus qu'un
métier je suis heureux parce que l'armée
pourquoi j'aime bien
j'aime bien les odeurs j'aime bien le
travail et la convivialité que les
clients merci beaucoup je dis bon soir
on termine ce journal de la semaine avec
une dernière image image de la
découverte d'une sépulture à marmoutier
en indre et loire
une seconde sépulture vient d'être mise
à jour dans le choeur de l'église de
l'abbaye dans un important qu'à vous
goûtez les auteurs des fouilles ont
découvert un cercueil de bois à
l'intérieur duquel se trouvait un autre
cercueil mais en plomb cette fois dans
ce cercueil
le squelette d'un homme mort en 16 110
et les spécialistes ont pu identifier
avec certitude
notamment grâce aux inscriptions qui ont
été conservés sur les parois du caveau
il s'agirait donc de la sépulture du
demi frère du roi henri iv fils naturel
du roi de navarre
antoine de bourbon charles de bourbon
qui fut archevêque de rouen
alors petite explication ce charles de
bourbon et bien c'était réellement le
demi frère d'henri iv son père
s'appelait antoine de bourbon
il avait une maîtresse louise de la
béraudière et donc le petit charles est
né en toute illégitimité à l'époque on
appelait ça un bâtard alors on va pas
vous raconter toute son histoire mais
sachez qu'à la fin de sa vie il avait
été nommé évêque précisément dans
l'abbaye de marmoutier c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a retrouvé là et heureusement
que la télé a fait un reportage en 1976
sinon aujourd'hui eh bien on l'aurait
tout simplement oublié à la semaine
prochaine